what up space fam goes in here for anime
opera and unless you've been living
under a rock with no internet connection
I'm sure you heard that this latest
development in Demon Slayer was the
craziest yet by far so definitely stay
tuned for that if you enjoy seeing these
chats reviews they want to keep them
coming the best thing can do is smash
that like button share this video with a
friend if you haven't be sure to
subscribe this is crucial
hit that notification bell or you will
miss future demons their shots reviews
and you don't want that since we really
seem to be approaching the crazy and
keep in mind there will be manga
spoilers in this video we are going to
be talking about the latest chapter
chapter 200 after all now without
further ado let's jump into it so last
chapter we left off as baby moves on was
evaporating in the sunlight finally the
big bad boss seemed to be defeated so
this chapter should be a happy ending
right if you expected that then you are
in for a very rude awakening that's not
how this mangaka rolls there are no
quote-unquote happy endings after a war
which is what this pretty much was now
we're going to see the aftermath of the
fight and it's unbelievably bad this
week the Shonan drum cover is deservedly
dedicated to the even slayer we see
tundra in the center again they're
showing him with normal eyes because
this infected eye is not very attractive
for the cover of the magazine we seen a
Zuko back to human that's what I'm
talking about and we see moves on being
mad so the cover is teasing a bit that
moves on might have survived the last
chapter however as we get to the colored
pages of the actual chapter we see that
the Sun is out and moves are continues
to disappear we're even told that the
enemy disappears so this should finally
be the end of this over 1,000 year old
demon king of pop we get another page of
some of the demon Slayers and pillars
this coloured spread is actually a
massive spoiler but I'll come back to
why that is later this is chapter 200
and like I said with such a big
milestone like a 200 chapter you know
it's gonna be a big and important one
this chapter is called the price of
victory so we're going to get a sense of
what defeating moves on the big victory
everyone wanted actually cost them we
start with kitty a crying sweating you
know the usual with eyes wide open he
almost looks like he's in this bill
that after all this time moves on is
finally dead we see Mullins lump of
flesh continued to disappear the members
of the Demon Slayer core are also
staring and in disbelief like I can't
believe we did it we actually killed
Musa we get an overhead view letting us
get some perspective here moves ons
flesh is super small compared to the
hole he made as a giant baby I'm
guessing they're gonna keep an eye on
the flesh until it totally disappears
because with moves on you can't be too
careful we see the damage of this battle
hat on the surroundings we see the
crumbling buildings totaled cars and the
books that were used to slow down moves
on still love that they fought him with
books there's a metaphor in there
somewhere something like we can use
books both philosophy and stories to
help us overcome our monstrous fear of
death which moves on represents then
after the sudden shock of what's
happened the demon center members begin
to cry and hug they proclaim that they
want they took down moves on tears of
joy and relief fall from their faces and
you can't blame them
this has been a difficult battle and
they were not favored to win at all and
so I think we've all wanted to celebrate
that's what usually happens in stories
right you celebrate beating the big bad
boss but the demon slayer mangaka is
gonna challenge that dimension and quick
we jump to kiria who practically
collapses from exhaustion but tells
everyone to treat the wounded the
effects of this battle are nowhere close
to over the demon slayer members have to
cut their celebration short there are
people saying that they have to save the
wounded and others saying not to cry
since they must stay focused now after
all now that the battle against Mouzon
is over the normal non Opie members of
the Demon Slayer core are the most
useful for healing the ones that took on
the majority of the fighting first we
see domain the Demon Slayer members want
to help him but he tells them not to
waste a medicine on him since he's gonna
die this is a big blow no doubt but Yomi
was definitely set up to die he's the
oldest an upper moon one kakushi bow
even told him that since he awakened the
demon seer mark at 27 years old he was
definitely gonna die soon in virtually
all cases people with demons earmarks
died by 25 the exception of course was
the great year Ichi the strongest demons
there in history and indeed it seems
like this series will
with your Ichi continuing to hold that
title which I like but beyond Gil may
already being on borrowed time because
the Demon Slayer market has aged he also
made it clear that he was ready to die
and that even lost his leg and continued
to fight until the end this just sped up
the inevitable his final request seems
to be for the demon slayer members to
let him die and for them to find some
young people to help
although Kiyomi is young at 27 in this
series there's an ongoing joke that he's
an old man
since most demon Slayers like our main
characters are considerably younger than
him then as gilma is passing over he
sees the orphans he took care of some
important things get cleared up here
they say they always wanted to apologize
for that day meaning the day that demon
attacked them they said they weren't
running away they just thought that they
had to protect yo me because he couldn't
see they were gonna get weapons and call
for help
ironic that kids were trying to save the
strongest pillar but he wasn't even a
pillar back then and he didn't even know
how strong he truly was
Kiyomi listens as they apologize for
kicking out kagaku who led that a whole
demon attack and if you didn't know his
I mean chose former senpai turned demon
moon was in fact one of Guillaume AIDS
orphans
he's the orphan who was caught by a
demon and traded the lives of all the
other kids in order to survive the other
kids had chased him away because he was
stealing temple money kai gaku is
definitely one of the easiest characters
to hate in this whole series selfish and
greedy right to the end the kids explain
to go maid that they would have
explained everything if morning came as
usual but they died before it did they
cried then go make rise Yomi apologizes
to them for not being able to protect
them they hug Yomi and tell him how much
they love him and how they've been
waiting for him the stone pillar thanks
them and they go on to heaven together
yo made eyes with tears of joy and a
smile on his face definitely one of the
most touching moments in the series thus
far but this is only the beginning of
the insane emotional rollercoaster that
is this chapter and since this was a
major debt that's saying a lot
next we see Mitsui who's being held by a
guru I told you guys last time that the
mangaka led us to worry about meet suti
since we saw her get hit by Mouzon but
we didn't see her
after that by the way the fact that Igor
is holding between his arms is cute to
see circumstances aside meet suti asks
if they want and iguras says that they
did Mouzon is dead and she says thank
goodness then we get unexpectedly
depressing news best girl meet suti says
her body doesn't even hurt meaning she's
going to die soon I was telling you guys
I thought that she would survive and I
really hope she would survive and that
she and a girl could live out a happy
boring ending in some farm somewhere or
something but it seems like it was not
to be the mangaka is not holding any
punches this is worse than Game of
Thrones for me it really is meet suti at
the young age of 19 is passing away
iguodala at there being blinded and
almost eaten by musong says he's gonna
die soon - so meet soon he won't be
alone I told you guys before and I'll
say it again this relationship hits me
harder than Romeo and Juliet it really
does meet suti says she doesn't want a
girl to die and apologizes for not being
very helpful with tears in her eyes
ego is not having it and asks her not to
talk like that he asks her to remember
the first day they met from meters
perspective she was but a burden to
iguras as she got lost and needed iguras
help but a girl plays a reverse uno card
and says that it's the opposite she
helped him that day and the days that
followed she saved him he liked that
despite the tragedy of the world
keep in mind ego no can be dark like
chicken Batman for me cago meet suti
acted like a normal girl he loved that
despite the fact that she was a pillar
and probably had a hard upbringing she
was so positive she would get excited
and smile over nothing she had a bubbly
air to her and she didn't let the
suffering of the world get her down when
ego spoke to her and he really enjoyed
it it made him feel like he was a normal
dude which was always what a girl wanted
he wanted to be normal and not someone
who had corrupted blood she made someone
like ego to smile and laugh and eager to
is sure that she had the same effect on
everyone else too eager I was pointing
out here how there are more ways to help
than just through strength and fighting
meat so he was endlessly bright and
friendly and in that way she saved a lot
of people's hearts you could or tells
her that she should be proud and that he
won't let anyone speak bad of her not
even meet suti herself there's a
of truth the eager those words meet
sorry helped in the fight but she also
helped make people feel better and even
motivated agora to reach new levels of
power that were indispensable in the
fight against Mouzon after Igor has done
meet suti cries in his arms she says
she's so happy and says that she likes
agudo and yes it's the I want to marry
you kind of like she says that the Meo
she ate with eager were the best and she
loved the way a girl used to look at her
so gently she begs you to take her as
his wife if they're born again as humans
oh man the fields yogoro says of course
and holds her closer as they both cry
and if you're like me you're probably
watering up too right now they are both
committed to doing better next time -
making each other happy and to not
letting each other die this confession
of feelings was so satisfying it's just
so sad that they can't be together in
this world so yes it seems like they're
gonna die
they said as much but significantly
enough we don't see them cross over so
we might hope against hope that somehow
they're wrong and that they'll get
married in this world after all
meet suti seems pretty lively for
someone that's just about to die next we
see Sanne me he's already at the
crossover point he sees his siblings in
what must be heaven then he finds his
mother and asks why she isn't going to
heaven but she says she can't as a demon
she killed her children so she can go to
heaven son of me being the absolute
selfless mad light he is smiles and says
that then he'll go to the other place
with his mother
he says he'll walk through hell carrying
his mother on his back however then son
amis dad shows up he separates them and
says that his wife is coming with him
remember that his father was an abusive
dude and he wasn't going to have him
either son of me is angry at his dad
telling him to let go of his mother but
he keeps falling backwards as he's told
that he can't go to heaven or hell yet
now I'm not 100% sure here who says this
his mother or father but the speech
bubble does seem to indicate the father
and it reads thank you for being my son
so one way of reading this is that his
father was extremely abusive and
deserves to go where he's going but he's
not completely without fear
for his son he wants him to go on living
and he's thankful for him and we know
that his mother feels the same way that
pretty much goes without saying son of
me regains consciousness and he's in
terrible shape but he's alright remember
Sonny and eNOS Kay pretty much have
immortality when it comes to their
ability to bounce back from usually
fatal wounds son of me gets to live for
now but if the demons their cursed mark
does and his life at 25 then he only has
four more years left to live
keep in mind the curse didn't kill your
Ichi but tsunami is definitely not out
of the woods yet we see in norske who
straight-up bites a helper the guys
alternate between saying he's crazy
healthy and dying you know usual
craziness Kay knowing him he'll be fine
then we get design into one of my
favorite characters in one of my
favorite moments it's funny
he just gets one panel but it's great he
tells the demon slayer members that if
he dies to tell his wife Natsuko that he
loves her someone answers she's not your
wife and he completely ignores them and
just keeps talking with tears in his
eyes he wants him to tell her he was
brave and he's eventually interrupted by
a guy saying he's talking just fine
meaning he'll be fine keep in mind ego
and Mitsui seem to be talking a lot too
so that should give us some hope there
as well I wondered why we didn't seize
any twenty no scaredy monsier marks
because that would have been pretty hype
but my guess is that mangaka wanted them
at least to have full lives
so she's somewhat nerfed them so they
could have a happy ending and I'm
totally okay with that
we then jump to give he's in bad shape
too and the helpers tell him not to move
but he keeps looking for the other half
of his bromance tangier oh he wants to
know if he's safe and he can't even wait
to get his treatment this is by far the
climax of the chapter and the most WTF
unexpected moment in demon slayer we see
pan john he's not moving
his head is down and he's being held up
by a helper the helpers crying saying
that Kendra is not breathing and that he
cannot get a pulse there's a lot of
crying - Iggy who gets an image of a
young healthy tundra smiling his bright
hopeful smile and contrasting that to
the current reality is too much
they usually stoic view is overcome by
tears
he puts tundra sword down as if telling
the corpse that the
/ he doesn't need to fight anymore gu
continues to cry saying that once again
he couldn't protect Han 0g who says that
he's only protected by others and asks
for forgiveness
obviously you gave it his all and even
lost an arm in the process but he can't
help but feel disappointed in himself
this senpai couldn't save his young
protégé we have helpers saying they're
sorry to naisu KO who's finally shown up
she's crying and running towards tun
zero we're told that the price of
victory is too great and indeed it seems
to be greater than anyone could have
imagined and that's the end of this
chapter okay so I know you're probably
thinking WTF a protagonist dying in a
shounen jump battle manga is definitely
a situation that few people saw coming I
can't think of one shounen jump battle
manga I've read where the protagonist
dies for good let alone a 15 year old
protagonist but mu Ichiro did die in
this series and he was even younger so
age is definitely not gonna stop anyone
kicking the bucket here now is the
series over know there will be more
chapters even if only one more that
helps wrap this up we haven't seen eager
enemy tree crossover we haven't seen
tons of crossover either you can bet
we'd see him reunite with his family if
he's really dead for good and he does
seem to be unless we get some equivalent
of Pokemon tears reviving him shout out
to Pokemon the first movie there is
still a lack of finality about egora
meet suti and Tundras death what does
seem to work against us is the coloured
spread that I referred to earlier at the
beginning of the chapter if you look at
it again after reading the chapter
you'll notice that all the guys on the
right side Guillaume 8 and 0 meet sorry
and II guro are supposed to die or be
dead and they're all smiling
aka at peace however on the Left we have
characters like mezu KO son and me GU in
those cans any two who we know will
survive and who are not smiling because
they're probably mourning over the
Fallen this cover spread along with the
facts of the chapter lead me to believe
that Tundra could be dead for good and
me tree and a guru could cross over soon
- unless there's some strange rule like
some people just get reborn right away
rather than going to
heaven or hell but I doubt there would
be that inconsistency with the portrayal
of the afterlife so there you have it we
have every reason to believe that our
protagonist Tundra is dead and that
Mitra and Iguodala die but also a bit of
hope that it's not final yet we'll have
to wait and see but at the very least we
should see an at peace hundred or
reunite with his family and as we go and
zani to getting married
I hope the mangaka at least gives us
that let me know what you are thinking
right now
are you sure that Tundra is dead is
there a chance of meet suti and ego no
surviving and having an idyllic country
life together
at least until 25 years old if the Demon
Slayer marker still applies without
demons so many questions left to be
answered but man the mangaka is holding
no punches was the feeding Muslim
necessary yes it was but it still sucks
to see the aftermath it truly is
heart-wrenching as many of you told me
it would be before I read it whatever
happens it's been worth the ride and if
we look at characters like Guillaume a
guru and Mitsui
their end wasn't ideal but they were
happy in the end and I think that's
important to keep in mind anyways that's
it for this unbelievable mind-blowing
chapter thank you so much for listening
if you enjoy these chapter reviews I
want to keep them going the best thing
you can do is smash that like button and
share this video with a friend if you
haven't be sure to subscribe and this is
crucial ring down notification bell or
you will miss the last few chapter
reviews a special thank you goes to our
patrons over on patreon who helped us
survive YouTube issues and who helped
make videos like this one possible first
and foremost I want to thank the legend
acknowledged by Lorde we go senpai sama
himself baby ray and the one tear
patrons the ones who stand atop all
clans stephen grata aloha nintendo world
stealers the school bus tyson Corino
acquire respect but they have fun and
chris loki and our pro heroes to your
patrons the one and only Gilgamesh
nothing but a fan Jason Wilson Odin
Anatoly kazansky
alpha do angel Cruz team Sparky 65 Rohan
Kapoor cricket XP $30 beat Ted no Ted
Salter Joel Stanton Barry Gucci
Jessica Calif on Alicia actor Lee by
Emperor otaku and jccc Wacha thank you
also
if you enjoy our work you can support
more of it by going over to patreon comm
anime up drawer and becoming a patron
today for as little as one dollar if you
do so you'll get your name featured in
future videos alongside these amazing
epic people right here and you'll even
get access to a private patient only
discord where we talk about anime life
and of course dank memes so check out
patreon.com
link in the description if you're
interested you can also now join the
YouTube channel and support more content
that way if you prefer whichever way you
choose to support us you can get the
same great benefits thanks again and
until next time see you space cowboy
[Music]
you
[Music]